on the client side it's having good
conversations now that's hard to measure
right because everyone's you know
expectations of good are different but
as long as you feel like you had a good
conversation and you somehow added value
or you learned something about that
client that you didn't know before that
conversation that was a good
conversation and obviously hopefully
getting in a forward action so you know
I think you know having a certain amount
of good client conversations a day
eventually it's a numbers game right So
eventually that will lead to forward
actions and that will lead to proposals
being sent out and that that is honestly
like the number one thing I look at on
the client side you know good
conversations good quality business
conversations it can be personal as well
but as long as you've had that good
conversation that that's what matters to
me the recruitment mentors podcast is
proudly sponsored by VIN cherry and the
award-winning Source breaker